good afternoon we start with some
breaking news Sky News has exclusively
obtained the blood test results at the
center of the paula radcliffe doping row
and they appear to exonerate her of any
wrongdoing
the British marathon world record holder
has been under intense pressure to
release the test scores after being
implicated in the continuing revelations
of blood doping in the world of
athletics the data does show readings
that would normally be above the limits
set by the International Athletics
Federation but we have established the
grounds on which the athletes was given
the all-clear for Sky Sports
correspondent Paul Kelso is here and has
been looking at the data afternoon Paul
tell us more so this all stems from the
leaked database of athletes blood tests
that was leaked to The Sunday Times and
the German broadcaster ard back in
August and around the reporting of that
case Paula Radcliffe was never named but
a British athlete a high-level British
athlete was cited as having recorded
high or abnormal blood test scores all
this comes down to the way athletes are
monitored these days their blood is
monitored to try and tackle blood doping
be it through transfusions or other
substances and what the experts in the
newspaper spoke to her saying was that
many many of the tests in this database
showed high levels which were indicative
certainly of suspicious levels and
possibly of doping paula radcliffe this
week revealed that she was the British
athlete named not named but referred to
in these reports and said that she cited
that she was she had nothing to hide and
that her blood scores were in fact not
unusual now I have seen the blood scores
that are in this database and if I can
talk you through them yeah she recorded
there are three tests that were flagged
in this database one showed a an off
score by which an athlete's blood is
measured it's a way of measuring the
capacity to carry red blood cells three
scores one of 114 point eight six one of
a hundred and nine point eight six on
one of one hundred and nine point three
now for an athlete training at sea
the cutoff marks set by the dope
nathie's is 103 okay so on the Facebook
those are highest numbers if you take
into the circumstances into account such
as training it altitude these numbers
don't look nearly so high and in fact
the experts cited by The Sunday Times
published their own research in which
they say the number at which you start
to test and look at these if someone's
been training altitude is a hundred and
eleven point seven so two of radcliffe
scores fall below a level set by the
experts the question is what was she
training it out she was she and the
answer that she has explained is she was
training it out two for all three tests
the third test the highest one which has
a mark of one hundred and fourteen point
eight six was taken the test was taken
immediately after a half marathon these
days they wait at least two hours after
a race to take a sample because it can
invalidate the test it's considered
about she says that puts her in the
clear and crucially she's saying she
believes that the experts relied upon by
the newspaper just did not have this
context they did not know where she been
training so to draw any conclusion that
there was any wrongdoing was erroneous
and which is presumably why those scores
were never investigated because they are
explainable
but then brings into question the the
way in which this became public which
presumably it should never have done
because it wasn't there for
investigation they were abnormal but
they weren't irregular in those terms it
became public through this antiquated
system of parliamentary privilege indeed
and that's something about which she is
furious
they were flagged these tests because
they showed an unusual number at the
time they were followed up by the
iwf she was target you're interested for
EPO of blood boosting substance and
cleared I spoke to her last night in
Brussels about these numbers and she was
very clear that she has nothing to hide
but that should not have been come out
in this way without the context that's
here these data needs to be looked at in
context by the right experts eirick
the water go back and go over again all
of this data UK anti-doping we can do
that as well I know that the idea of an
effort done that I've requested the
independent experts do that and I have
those reports so I'm very glad I had to
wait to get those in place but I'm very
glad that I now have those in place and
they can tell you you don't have three
values so that crossed any threshold not
when you apply the context of whether
the tests followed a period of altitude
training always carried out at altitude
and not when you apply whether the the
two hour rule that it cannot be used a
test taken within two hours certainly of
a hard competition and also of training
is not valid and so that rules out two
of the tests they're referring to and
the other one is not above the threshold
so they're Paula Radcliffe in her own
words this is complex stuff it's a
complex area but I think the complexity
in what we've seen here from actually
seeing these numbers for the first time
what it demonstrates is what paula
radcliffe and many others have been
saying all along if you introduce this
data into the public domain without
context and without expert analysis it
can be misread and the crucial thing
she's saying is it didn't have the
context these are not these are blood
tests they are not drugs tested he's not
a test you can fail and that is why
athletes like Brad Cliff feel they've
been placed in a bind and it's why the
sport is in having such difficulty
establishing in the public mind what can
we believe and what can't Paul thank you